[Music]
why do we feel so alone when
we're in the crowd how to
keep going when your feet don't even know the
way
[Music
] what to believe when it's really
just a point of view
[Music]
where to go when the only feeling is
who shouldn't be conceding goals
faces
banfield from that is to see the dream has god
shot to death by credit
the daughter of futsal europe a feeling da
ship to love we found love love love
love love life a place where people
can see  and exchange experience on a
universal topic jeff chiu wai wai wai tim
lopes
will now be worth 10 clovis efe
is a space that will serve for
people who want to go on a
journey around skin transformation,
mainly we offer a
space where the  hot individual assess your
next case and make a decision
towards your own
potential brazil is at a time of change
i think brazil's future depends
on individuals
[Music]
there was ava  No